[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
projet de loi énergie renouvelable un
accord ambitieux obtenu
dans un contexte géopolitique et
énergétique très tendu la France doit
trouver des solutions pragmatiques pour
assurer sa sécurité d'approvisionnement
dans cette perspective un compromis a
été trouvé entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale sur le projet de loi
d'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable 4 mois seulement
après son dépôt
cet accord permettra de déployer plus
rapidement des énergies indispensables à
la préservation de notre souveraineté et
à l'atteinte de nos objectifs
climatiques le texte issu des
négociations conforte les principaux
apports du Sénat adoptés en novembre
2022 à la casinine limitée
introduit au Sénat le dispositif global
de planification territoriale du
déploiement des énergies renouvelables à
l'initiative des élus locaux a ainsi été
confortée et renforcés tout projet
d'énergie renouvelable soutenue dans le
cadre des appels d'offres sera désormais
soumis un bilan carbone et à une
contribution territoriale au partage de
la valeur
cette contribution permettra de financer
les projets des communes et de leur
groupement en faveur de la transition
énergétique dans les zones
d'accélération
identifiées dans le cadre de cette
planification des mesures de
simplification procédurale permettront
de déployer les projets plus rapidement
à l'initiative du Sénat des
assouplissements réglementaires
initialement temporaires ont par exemple
été pérennisé pour accélérer
l'instruction des projets le texte de
compromis issu des travaux des députés
et sénateurs sera examiné prochainement
par les deux Chambres
pour en savoir plus consultez le site du
Sénat
[Musique]